who's that  there's nobody are you doing here Frank  how many to get you no thank you  it's for Mom good do something for her  she want he made me promise that you and  I together would take a trip and spread  her ashes over elections if we do this  you'll never have to see me little  respect wouldn't hurt you in the lady  department lady department where's that  lose it next to housewares aisle 7 well  you made enough to ride the way  [Music]  you know they say it's inevitable that  you turn into your father I don't think  that'll ever happen  where did you meet or what a bus Detroit  she dropped a book and I picked it up I  never told her I rode that bus in the  wrong direction every day for the three  weeks waiting for a drop something just  take on  [Music]  not the past control you  [Music]  this is what mom wanted us to see  [Music]  you